[Music]
thank you for joining us on spectator tv
kate and julian kate in this week's
magazine you look at putin's billions
and whether the sanctions by the west
and other countries are really working
can you give us a run-free to begin with
of what has been put on the table so far
so there have been a vast array of
sanctions uh coming from the west
targeted at russia from freezing the
accounts of notorious oligarchs to
freezing russian banks and companies out
of financial system the goal has
essentially been to push russia and its
economy to the outer limits of the
global economy and to keep them out of
as much as possible putin's central bank
assets of which they're about 600
billion dollars worth about a third of
those have have managed to been frozen
by by the international community
because they're foreign assets so
quite a lot has been done but what this
article really looks at is arguably one
of the most important sanctions that was
not brought in early and in many places
still hasn't been brought in and that
would be on russia's energy and without
bringing in serious sanctions on russian
energy what we've seen as this war has
caused energy prices to spike the cost
of oil the cost of gas all going up is
that putin has actually been raking it
in at the moment he's bringing in about
800 million dollars a day and about a
fourth of that is coming from germany
alone
and so when you put that into
perspective we can talk about economic
sanctions all we want but the west is
still very much funding putin's war
chest um it's difficult for him to spend
a lot of that money and and i think
that's one area where you can argue that
perhaps the sanctions are working but
but the point of this article is that it
really is a mixed picture and if the
goal was to completely
[ __ ] russia's economy and to deprive
putin of these of his funds for his for
his war chest arguably we have not been
all that successful
julian do you think the sanctions could
be backfiring
well first of all i think i agree with
almost everything that kate has has just
said um i would say though that economic
sanctions i think always going to play
sort of second fiddle to the the more
important issue which is making sure
that russia loses the war in ukraine
itself and you know so far the evidence
is that militarily it's been a disaster
for russia i think that's probably the
single most important thing at the
moment um as far as the economic
sanctions are concerned i i agree that
they've probably backfired in the in the
short term um in the sense that they've
actually sort of raised the the price of
the key commodities that russia is
selling they've still been able to find
good markets outside uh europe and the
rest of the west
but i think in the longer term they will
be far more effective and i think that
that is the bigger issue for for russia
um yes they've been able to sell some
more energy and other commodities at
higher prices now but it's pretty clear
that the long-term tide is moving
against them you know europe will slowly
diversify away from from russian oil and
gas and that's a big hit to the economy
uh on top of that you've got all the if
you like the softer stuff as well so the
you know the brain drain from from
russia the the cultural isolation all
those sorts of things they may not have
much immediate impact on the the
headline economic numbers but they're
undoubtedly painful
and the fact that so many people who
have supported putin more or less
explicitly over the last few years the
oligarchs have been hit hard as well i
think there'll be some sort of price for
to pay for that in the future
but in the meantime i think you have to
be realistic and ask what the
alternatives were i mean clearly no
sanctions against russia would not have
been acceptable
the other extreme a complete ban on
buying russian oil and gas would have
triggered an immediate recession in the
west so i think we had to be realistic
and
personally i think we probably got the
balance about right kate how realistic
is it for germany to reduce its energy
supply when it comes to russia obviously
there's pressure uh from other leaders
for
the germans to do this but it is easier
said than done
oh it's much easier said than done but i
think that that's one of the the points
of the piece which is that um the west
wants to pat itself on the back and say
look at this amazing work we're doing
we've taken every step we can to be an
ally of ukraine and the truth is we
haven't taken every step we can because
for all the reasons that that julian
just pointed out um you know it is near
impossible for for germany to overnight
decide that it's no longer going to
import russian gas not least because
other countries that are more energy
independent like the us have not been
especially helpful you know there's been
murmurs that the us might help supply
energy to to countries like germany but
we haven't really seen that come to
fruition so um you know and unless you
want to essentially damn your society to
the lights going out in a recession
overnight
it's not possible but you know that
phrase just keeps coming to my mind this
is the one thing we didn't want to have
happen and the fact that putin is
expected to bring in more income this
year in 2022 when he launched his
full-scale invasion than he did last
year was clearly not the point of these
sanctions and i think we we need a more
honest conversation around it i
completely agree with julian that in the
medium to long term this is going to be
extremely painful for russia and
actually in the short term their economy
is expected to contract by 10 this year
4 next year whilst the growth figures
and the predictions for the west don't
look great they're nothing as bad as
that and putin is starting to take some
very dangerous decisions and he's
playing some very dangerous games by
threatening to cut off food exports from
ukraine's port in odessa threatening you
know starting to to play with how much
gas he's actually importing to europe
you know suggesting look i can turn off
the taps if i want to um the result if
if he gets very serious about either of
those things is that people will die
from uh from the cold and from
starvation these are really serious
games and and he's playing them because
of the sanctions he wants to see them
disappear they are hurting russia
there's no doubt about that
but he is in in my opinion in the short
term
a stronger position when it comes to
european energy in particular we have
found ourselves in a position in part
because of these sanctions in which
europe is more dependent on russian gas
than russia is for for european cash and
that income because he's had such a
windfall of profits in the first half of
this year
julian what options are there really for
these countries like germany and the
west when it comes to
things they could do which would
perhaps make these sanctions more
effective but also not you know
backfiring so much that suddenly this uh
big domestic backlash which he touched
on
well actually one thing to say first is
that even if russia is in some sense
winning the the sanctions war in the
short term it's very much a hollow
victory and if we take the the russian
ruble for example the currency um that
has strengthened to something like a
seven year high against the us dollar
which is quite remarkable um but that's
been at the cost of a combination of
significant capital controls uh in
russia itself
and also a collapse in domestic demand
so yes russia is still getting lots of
money coming in from selling commodities
to the west and also to countries like
china and india
but at the same time it's not able to
import much from the west uh things that
it wants everything from military goods
to consumer goods and so on and so on so
that has propped up the balance of
payments which at face value looks
extremely healthy but underlying that
there are deep structural problems in
the in the russian economy that aren't
going to go away anytime soon um and i
think that's probably the the way that
countries like like germany should be
looking at this i mean um you know
ideally we in the uk or others in the us
might like germany to cut off
imports of energy from russia straight
away but
i simply don't think that's realistic
there are lots of countries germany as
one italy is another who rely on russia
for maybe sort of 40 percent of their
energy particularly things like natural
gas and you can simply cannot
find alternative sources of energy that
quickly uh even with the the best will
in the world so i think we have to
accept that some countries like german
and italy are always going to be behind
the pack in terms of reducing their
dependency on on russian energy
but importantly they are signaling their
willingness to do so over the medium to
longer term um and that is having a big
impact if you look at for example
you know russian equity market that's
still pretty depressed because they're
taking a longer-term view
of the viability of the russian economy
and the energy model in particular so
i wouldn't necessarily say that you know
germany and italy and the others need to
do more now but they're absolutely right
they should be signaling their intention
uh to reduce their dependency on russian
energy over time and i think that's
where most the damage will come
and kate if we look at the illustration
of this week's spectator
ultimately it's putin surrounded by all
this gold and even if he is uh you know
raking in more than he would be doing
without the sanctions when it comes to
some of that revenue
he is limited as julian mentioned what
he can actually spend it on and for
example with things such as um
the war and getting the right military
equipment it is gonna be quite tricky
for him to use that money in a way which
gets him exactly what he needs isn't it
yes and i think that's uh the flip side
of this where you can say that sanctions
are are having their effects uh it is
going to be increasingly difficult for
putin to import the the military
equipment he needs he's already finding
it very hard to get a high-tech
artillery back into russia
and to julian's original point about you
know what we care about most ukraine
actually winning this war it's estimated
by uk figures that russia has already
lost a third of its ground force that is
sent into ukraine
since it began this war and and that
includes a thousand military vehicles
that includes a hundred planes that's
going to be very hard for him to to to
get back into uh his military uh as well
you know he he's been known for years to
be working with russian businessmen to
smuggle in microchips that are necessary
for military operations but patrols are
increasing it's getting harder to uh
circumvent
you know u.s exports and all the rest of
it so um you know this is an area where
in the medium term he is definitely
going to be feeling that pain but
because he does have access to so much
cash and he's using a lot of that to
stimulate artificially the russian
economy what it can buy him is time and
that is a very real concern us
especially as you know
i understand julian's point about you
know we need we need to be accepting
that germany can't wean itself off
russian gas overnight but i'm slightly
less generous uh to chancellor schultz
uh and and the government in germany
right now because
there's been a lot of talk of sending
ukraine weapons and more military
supplies and the ukrainians are saying
we haven't seen this yet um you
certainly get a sense from germany that
that they would prefer for this to end
sooner rather than later and you don't
always get the sense
that that they feel very strongly how
that has to end because this is causing
so much domestic pain um so as long as
putin has that time and he's able to
artificially stimulate his own economy i
think that's really bad news for ukraine
winning this war
and julian in terms of time frame kate's
touching obviously the pressure how the
current situation could give putin time
for these sanctions to be really
successful do you think they have to
stay in place for for a long time to
come
uh well yes i do i think the obvious
thing to do is to keep them in place as
long as putin is in power i think it's
very hard to to see
the west re-engaging with russia as long
as putin is in power and presumably as
long as putin is in power russia will
hold on to whatever parts of ukraine
it's it's already taken um so i think
that we have to be in this for the for
the long haul
um as kate said this is this is very
difficult to do i think it's probably
easier for us to do in in the uk and
possibly also in the us than it is for
for some european countries but i agree
with kate there's some worrying signs of
you know backsliding uh kate picked on
germany i'm going to pick on france
where you know president macron seems to
take the view that we shouldn't you know
do much to upset putin um i hate to
throw around words like appeasement but
it does feel like that that you know
some countries are
too concerned about the potential uh
blowback on their own economies to
uh to take on somebody who is you know
clearly a murderous tyrant who's doing
lots of harm to his neighbors but also
even to his own country so i think
politically it's going to be very
difficult for all countries to stay the
course against
russia and continue with the sanctions
but frankly i think we have to we have
to until there's a regime change in
russia itself
and kate just finally um touching on
those points um we have a situation
where there's clearly concern among some
governments that there is backsliding uh
by other european leaders
um as as we've just had macron's idea
that putin should not be humiliated and
so forth so is this going to be a case
when it comes to sanctions of who blinks
first
yeah i think so
we have this dynamic where we have a
shrinking russian economy and
as julian said a murderous tyrant who's
sitting on cash in time but is
struggling to spend that cash and at
some point may start to run out of time
but you also have western governments
that are looking at very stagnant
economic growth dealing with a cost of
living crisis across the west
in which people are getting very
frustrated and very angry we have an
inflation crisis on our hands too
and there is a question as to who can
sustain this longer um and you do hear
worrying um murmurs from from europe
that you know perhaps we're going to
have to come to some uh uh faster
solution um and what that actually means
for ukraine and for the sovereignty of
ukraine and for the safety of ukrainian
people doesn't always feel like it's at
the forefront of that discussion so you
know we always have to be realistic when
we consider this and um you know
realistic in what kinds of negotiations
might happen realistic in time frames um
but
if the west blinks first and and blinks
quickly and rapidly um you could
certainly find yourself in a situation
where putin isn't just gaming the
economic sanctions he actually also
manages to game the military situation
between russia and ukraine
thank you kate thank you julian
[Music]
you